so I had this moment while playing
Kingdom Come deliverance where I had to
break into someone's house to steal a
ring as part of a quest for a group of
Millers that as it turns out are
secretly an organization of thieves and
I said to myself wow this really is a
lot like an Elder Scrolls game and I in
no way mean that to be derogatory while
Bethesda's series of open-world RPGs
have been a huge influence on many games
no one's really try to straight-up make
an Elder Scrolls game but that also
wouldn't be giving kingdom come enough
credit because for all of the parallels
in designs and visuals actually playing
Kingdom Come feels like a vastly
different experience from Elder Scrolls
so in this video I want to talk about
how these two games can feel so
different despite being so similar in
how Bethesda could actually learn a
thing or two from Kingdom Come as an
aside for this comparison I will be
using the Elder Scrolls for oblivion due
to its visual similarities and also
because it's my personal favorite
everything I say though pretty much
applies to all Elder Scrolls games being
a game built with history in mind
Kingdom Come is immediately different
than the fantasy based world of oblivion
practically everything the game does is
meant to simulate what it was actually
like in medieval Bohemia that means
stuff like needing to bathe regularly
managing injuries and eat food before it
spoils this makes buying food at the
shop or drink at the tavern important
because they have tangible benefits that
are needed to keep you alive compare
this to oblivion where food does have
small effects but generally isn't really
useful on its own and is better served
as ingredients in a potion you'll never
need to stock up on carrots before
making a long trek to the next town
which becomes second nature in Kingdom
Come in fact a lot of the objects
scattered around oblivion don't really
have much of a gameplay benefit as a
result taverns and markets end up being
more like window dressing to flesh out
the world meanwhile every shop in
Kingdom Come feels important because
they all sell stuff you need to survive
an average day the same goes for
sleeping in a Bolivian you only really
need to sleep in order to level up and
any bed will do you'll also recover all
your health but the same thing can be
accomplished by simply waiting an hour a
system I abused quite regularly that's
not the case in Kingdom Come though
where the only way to regain health is
to sleep it off or you
consumable items beds also work with
what is likely kingdom comes most
contentious feature its save system
there is no auto-saves outside certain
quest moments and you'll only manually
save by sleeping in a bed you own or by
purchasing expensive bottles of savior
snaps it's a radically different
approach to oblivion save anywhere any
time system and results in two different
experiences in Kingdom Come saving some
poor villager being accosted on the road
might not be worth the risk if you die
and lose an hour of progress you're
forced to think about every choice you
make and what you end up choosing feels
more important because of this this is
rarely the case in Oblivion where you
can quickly save at any time and retry
that locked door as many times as you
want but don't take me as saying that
being able to save at any time is bad or
anything
after all oblivion doesn't want you to
get stuck or lose hours of progress it
wants you to go on an adventure right
from the beginning you're free to go
wherever you want and find a fun quest
to engage in with no worries about save
limitations or not having enough food
kingdom come simply prefers a more
rigorous approach and the advantage of
kingdom comes a way of doing things is
that it forces you to live in its world
and roleplay when you're making a long
trek you need to make sure you've packed
enough food and are well-rested and when
it's starting to get dark and you're low
on energy there's a real sense of relief
when you see that in on the side of the
road and oblivion I would only really
stop at an inn because well frankly I
kind of wanted a roleplay it a bit now
neither approach is inherently right or
wrong but I do appreciate the appeal of
what Kingdom Come is going for and I
think it makes certain situations more
impactful take for example the Thieves
Guild and Oblivion and kingdom comes
equivalent and oblivion I joined the
Thieves Guild not out of any real desire
for money or financial reasons you don't
really need it I joined because it's a
fun quest narrative where you go around
stealing a bunch of stuff the opening
hours of Kingdom Come however leave you
with very little beyond the clothes on
your back money is necessary to get
access to the food and other important
items you need to stay alive so when
presented with the faster but much more
dangerous option of becoming a thief I
took it the game systems made a life of
crime in appealing means of survival a
changeable
I'll do what you want come to your
senses hey great this isn't to say that
Kingdom Come is perfect that save system
can be hella frustrating when things go
bad and the devs do seem to be
backpedaling on it a bit with an
upcoming patch that'll let you save
whenever you quit which i think is a
pretty good compromise there's also the
lock-picking and pickpocketing minigames
that just don't seem to work right
sometimes which can be really
frustrating and then exacerbated by the
save system but again they've said
they're going to address this so good on
the developers for listening to fan
feedback so quickly the games also buggy
as hell something that Elder Scrolls
also shares there is an aspect I think
oblivion does better though and that's
in its playable character your character
is given the bare-bones setup of being
in jail but after that you're free to
come up with whatever backstory and
personality you want you also don't have
any voice lines and the dialogue options
are minimal with very little personality
the idea being that you will fill in
that personality yourself the ability to
create whatever person you want as an
avatar for you to roleplay goes well
with the freedom based design of the
gameplay kingdom comes approach is more
like The Witcher with protagonist Henry
having a built-in personality to cope
sees both of you know honorable man
should touch them
that's the executioner's job this ends
up clashing with the rest of the game to
do anything style Henry may talk about
how much he respects honor and appalls
thievery but right after that I can
instantly kill a random woman and steal
her stuff I consistently feel like what
Henry says and what I want Henry to do
are at odds with each other a problem I
feel Bethesda also faced with fallout 4
is protagonist Shawn's out there
codsworth I need to find him
so while it's not perfect it's pretty
clear that Kingdom comes more hardcore
ideas have won me over but I'm not
trying to say that the next Elder
Scrolls it needs to be some hardcore
survival sin
I like how oblivion and Skyrim are light
hearted and the freedom to go wherever I
want and have a good adventure is just
what I want sometimes and I don't think
that should go away but with the next
ultra Scrolls being inevitable at some
point in the future I think it would
really benefit Bethesda if they took a
look at how Kingdom Come is pushing this
type of game design forward
you